hi my name is Paul Davis and today we're
looking at the most legendary finger
picking pattern of all time Travis
speaking and how it can turn three
simple chords into something wonderful
it's named after the great Merle Travis
and although there's a ton of variations
on this pattern what they all have in
common is the thumb it's a bass pattern
that starts on the root note in this
case tucci and alternates to another
bass notes to get the illusion the bass
player accompanying us and if we were to
move to another chord let's say a minor
I simply grab that cord and move my
thumb to the new root note open a string
so if you want to add another chord we
can add the C major for example and we
don't have to change anything because
root note is already on the a string
great now we can move back to the tonic
the G chord we play each chord for two
bars so in total we've got this one
[Music]
I'm slightly palm-muting the bass notes
with my right hand sweet but the beauty
of Chara speaking isn't here yet
you see we create a nice and elegant
play between the thumb and the index and
middle finger of my picking hand on beat
one we add the second string to the
pattern one two I'm playing it with my
middle finger one two
on the first after beat the one and I
played a third string with my index here
[Music]
let's slow it down a little bit
so there's no it falls on the offbeat
exactly in between the thumbs
like this
alright let's add one more and this one
falls exactly in between second and
third beats and it is to be stirring
again
and we play this twice on the G chord
and then we move over to the a minor
boards and we play exactly the same only
make sure your thumb goes up do it a
string wonderful and when we move to the
C chord our big again doesn't change at
all we simply grab the C major chord we
play it twice again and back to G and
now we have a vars now let's speed it up
again like this
[Music]
all right and this is the fundament of
our little finger style part but we can
add a lot of little things to make it
sound even more magical for starters
let's add a melody that runs through
this harmony the first bar stays exactly
the same
but halfway bar to our melody walks up
from the B via the sea to the deep
for one and three on the B string that
is
and the amana denotes fall exactly on
the athletes in between the thumbs
so played a few times to get the hang of
the timing and don't forget to keep that
thumb going
[Music]
awesome so it's really turning into a
song instead of just three cores now we
move to the a minor and we do exactly
the same
[Music]
but now our manatee walks up from sea
via D to the high e string and the
timing is exactly the same
wow this is so good but we have to go on
we go to the C chord
but the right before we get there we
play the open B string after which we
hammer on into the sea
like this and now let's add the pattern
back
so transitions from a minor to C
[Music]
great so now we have to move back to GE
and let's walk down via the B note the
bass note
and just before he goes at aji
coordinates added be Stern again like
this from sea
[Music]
that IBS tree is lovely so now we've got
eight beautiful and vibrant bar sounding
like this
[Music]
and sweet so the little ending I played
is sort of a turnaround we're just two
notes a B and C and back down played on
the Alpha beats
[Music]
and there we are each finger has its own
basic rule but combined it's an
intricate play of notes it just sounds
wonderful together and there's a few
ways we can spice this up again we can
add some rolls to make it more dramatic
[Music]
or we can add the slab of course so it
has some drums to our plane
[Music]
alright so that was the legendary Travis
speaking pattern all the taps are
available in my patron [__] and I want
to thank you so much for watching it
really means a lot and what would even
mean more is if you would like this
video because it tells me you and George
watching it as much as I had making it
and besides those are good for karma
talking about karma subscribing even get
you more points so just before we roll
into the new year make sure to hit that
subscribe button thank you so much have
a wonderful day this was Paul and I see
you next time with another video Cheers
[Music]